financial markets all over the world fell yesterday after Standard & Poor's on Friday downgraded our country's debt we are no longer triple-a now I want to talk about this for a second okay I consider myself a patriot but I want to say we may not have the best debt rating but as I mentioned last night I think there are some things we will always be triple-a in take a look hey America we're number one in monster-dog and nobody has more fun dads we still lead the world in Jack Nicholson impersonators lower back tax and animatronic presidents reveler we have the most Beyonce summer homes and the newest Mexico we've got the boat shirtless arrests the most talented pre-diabetic teenagers and the best-dressed dogs on the planet all that plus truck nuts [Music] you okay not to truck the hood and get me just chant truck cuts don't do that can't do that you can't switch over from USA to truck nuts [Applause]